hello the Internet aren't you I'm done
we're the slow mo guys and I feel like
for this one Dan we should just crack on
everyone knows we're gonna smash this
mirror was that a joke crack crack on it
wasn't
oh well good work anyway so thank you
very much gonna get hammer smash the
mirror two pieces let's go
are you aware of the seven years bad
luck I'm currently on 23 years at a
minute bad luck so that's not a multiple
of seven so I guess you know every
glance them down yeah okay okay good
glass breaks rapidly so it wouldn't be a
high-res one we're going to shoot low at
120,000 frames a second pressures on
present hell they've really really got
one mirror here we'll get it yeah why
not
I'm going to frame it so that you can
see the reflection of this one in the
mirror I like it so it's like you're
throwing it straight at the lens I've
never missed so we'll actually be like
you it'll be like you throwing a hammer
at a hammer that destroys itself I
reckon to look cool you ready yeah flip
an egg the hammer went right through
poor alright so I'm playing this back
sped up this is the equivalent of if we
were shooting this in two thousand five
hundred frames per second yeah which is
why we usually shoot so this will be a
normal camera yeah this will be way too
shits it's 10 billion now that tells us
nothing yeah one frame that is so far
yeah you definitely need to slow that
down a lot so this is a hundred twenty
thousand frames a second just stopped
barely looks like it's moving okay oh
god you see that shock wave yeah hold on
let me do it frame by frame
all right honestly they show the matrix
where the heart hits the building it's
exactly like that the thing is I was
watching at the time I was like yeah
there's no way that happens did they
know or did they just guess did they
know that was no happen so there's a
shock wave that moves through the glass
before the glass cracks and I've asked
cracks into the chakra
let's lapse into the bowl that's awesome
they were right the helicopter alright
let's speed up again ah lens flare we
keep this amazing
so we've recreated with a hammer what
they did with a helicopter into a
building now I want to try with a much
bigger pane of glass
let's try get some more lens flares it
look oh that's stunning there's a bit of
rainbow there as well nice I like for
some select moments the Sun is
reflecting off a piece of mirror that's
happening in the air it's straight into
the lenses face so I hit the middle the
glass right yeah the hammer went all the
way to the back here
hit hit that and bounce off I just
realized you almost smashed another
video I know there's a pane glass there
oh if you fell through that you would be
absolutely mullet you would when you
look at it really show sharp tiny little
shard
that's real glass is a savage another's
plastic Walmart mirrors target ones good
a thank you you're really good at like
bizarre stuff you could put an axe
handed wherever I've got a very specific
set of skills and they're all useless I
can throw a lopsided weird directly into
his quads yes that was cool
yeah was the frame rate was definitely
needed hopefully one day cameras that
can do 120,000 frames a second also do
it in like 4k how do you mean I'll be
the dream which would probably be 58 by
then yeah well then at that point over
ran out of bad luck there so I have to
redo this again good all right ah keep
nailing my osaka'
I keep trying that's my so what yet
you're right now 30 years bad luck
that's older than me so you've got more
bad luck to come then you've actually
lived yet so we'll be 58 by the time I
don't really yes
haha he just gets that one did you
really love I just guessed it just grew
up around the solution to the HIV I was
like okay so by the time your Luck's run
out we'll be able to film it again poor
Kate I have another seven years bad luck
alright we're gonna wait for technology
at this point okay well hopefully you
enjoyed that video um pretty pretty
brief one should follow since we're
subscribe to the second channel simian
Ella lens got you blinded him
yeah completely blind no like I'm in
school with my watch again so I had a
teacher in the eyes who did you get in
the eye into the school mr. leer I got
this to war
I could have George once he gave me a
Friday detention I was just like George
even Friday can't first name a teacher
you know in secondary school just not on
hopefully enjoy that video we'll see you
in the next one hopefully and if you
wait around 30 or so years we'll be back
doing this one again more bad luck